when you've had meat in your mouth the
way I have you just know what's a good
steak I like the taste of steak well
seasoned steak is prime I also don't do
raw steak
I do juicy steak I can eat steak every
single day even though it's not good for
you I get upset when I go to restaurants
and you don't have a1 sauce what's the
point I'm really excited to try these
steaks I'm trying to smell to see if
smells expensive or cheap this one seems
a little bare something I feed my dog or
cat seasonings very good though if
that's not breaking down as well as this
when I chewed it like it's good when you
chew it the aftertaste tastes cheap this
seems to be a little bit overcooked
maybe it's not as high-quality see this
looks nice it's got a little fat looks
like I've had some marbling in it this
one in the middle seems good this you
see this red is a No but at the same
time like it's a yes because let it all
that juice this is if a slim jim was
done right like if a slim jim was in
steak for him tender and really like
breaks down in your mouth properly when
you're chewing up it's hard to tell it
really is this one is kind of like Chris
and Burke but it's like chewy at the
same time it still has its flavor and
juice I'm not mad at this one tastes
like I didn't $10 I'm probably gonna be
so wrong this one is super super tasty
like this one needs a 1 sauce this one
doesn't so that means that it's not the
most expensive these two out here seem
to be the best quality I could be wrong
this one's wet but it's something that
rich people might like this might be a
chicken
this is the most expensive stack this is
the second most expensive and this is
the leaf middle sheet this is expensive
and this is like a most expensive middle
ground cheap I'm correct about every day
I'm gonna reward myself with some middle
ground see okay wait let me try it again
oh all three right this is the reason I
won't buy a Gucci purse because I'm not
there yet so I enjoy ASOS right here in
the middle but not Charlotte Russe this
one was a little bit easy to figure out
because you can just tell by the quality
this just looks overcooked or just
doesn't look like grade-a meat I'd still
eat this stick
I'd still eat this stick and sure would
eat the hell out of this stick around
this and a one for this to be good so
yeah long story short I love ASOS
[Music]